[Musica]
[Applauso]
negli ultimi anni abbiamo assistito con
con frequenza crescente a cataclismi che
solo fino a qualche decennio fa ci
sembravano
inimmaginabili come per esempio i
cambiam fenomeni metereologici estremi
causati dal riscaldamento globale e più
recentemente la pandemia da
covid-19 in questo intervento parlerò di
come una delle chiavi per affrontare
questo genere di problemi si trovi
almeno in parte proprio nel piatto in
cui
mangiamo si sa da tempo che per
affrontare le crisi ecologiche della
nostra epoca è necessario Porre un freno
all'invasione dell'uomo di territori
tropicali incontaminati
durante la pandemia di covid-19 Abbiamo
cominciato a riflettere se questa
invasione di territori incontaminati
aumenti anche il rischio dell'emergere
di malattie infettive dagli animali
selvatici che sono nocive per l'uomo Tra
questi ci sono presum bilmente il virus
del quelli causa dal virus dell'H
dell'ebola e del
covid-19 le foreste tropicali ricoprono
un ruolo fondamentale questo perché per
via di uno sviluppo più ridotto rispetto
ad altri luoghi del pianeta sono ancora
particolarmente ricche di stock di
carbonio e di fauna selvatica Tuttavia
negli ultimi decenni le frontiere
agricole hanno invaso le foreste
tropicali e i cacciatori sono penetrati
in zone sempre più remote decimando la
fauna
locale in uno studio pubblicato con dei
colleghi sulla rivista lanset siamo
giunti alla conclusione che per
affrontare questi problemi è necessario
ridurre il consumo di cibi che sono
generati dagli animali d'allevamento
Perché il nostro consumo di cibi che
derivano dagli animali d'allevamento
potrebbero incrementare il rischio di
malattie infettive che hanno origine
negli animali selvatici dei
Tropici perché la crescente domanda di
proteine animali ha portato
un'espansione dei Pascoli e delle
coltivazioni di di concimi senza
precedenti nelle foreste tropicali
questo crea delle aree di transizione
tra città e Foreste tra foreste zone
abitate dall'uomo in cui aumenta il
contatto tra animali selvatici animali
domestici e essere umano e quindi il
rischio di trasm di trasmissione di
malattie
infettive tuttavia le epidemie non sono
l'unica ragione per cui Dovremmo cercare
di
limitare l'incremento della della
produzione di animali d'allevamento
Perché a questo punto ci chiediamo Le le
gli allevamenti di
animali ricoprono un ruolo così
importante nella riduzione del
riscaldamento globale questo è perché
fra tutti i sistemi di produzione
agricola gli allevamenti animali hanno
la più forte la più grande impronta
ambientale noi sappiamo che al momento
si prevede al momento che la popolazione
umana continuerà a crescere per quasi
tutto il secolo
corrente Nelle economie avanzate il
consumo di carne e derivati ha raggiunto
un plaut a livelli insostenibili sia per
la salute umana che per l'ambiente nel
frattempo nei paesi in via di sviluppo
si ha avuto luogo una crescita economica
rapida la quale solitamente porta un
incremento del consumo di cibi di
origini animale ora se la popolazione
umana continua a crescere e ad adottare
ricche di cibi di origini animali è
probabile che entro il 2050 il le
emissioni di gas serra prodotte nel
settore agricolo aumenteranno tra il 30
al 40% questo rende improbabile il
nostro obiettivo di mantenere l'aumento
medio della temperatura bene al di sotto
dei 2°
ctig Come
dicevamo gli allevamenti hanno una porta
impronta ambientale se prendiamo in
considerazione tutti regni agricoli l'80
per sono utilizzati per Pascoli e e
coltivazioni di
concimi quasi il 15% di tutte le
emissioni di gas serra indotte dall'uomo
hanno origine negli allevamenti
Ovviamente questo crea una una una
situazione di grande preoccupazione e vi
è crescente consenso nella nella
comunità scientifica che anche qualora
adottassero tutte le migliori pratiche
gestionali e tecnologie nell'agricoltura
non sarà possibile SP amare la crescente
popolazione mondiale senza
compromettere l'ecologia senza
compromettere la stabilità ecologica del
pianeta se non attuiamo anche delle dei
cambiamenti radicali nelle nostre
diete ora vi chiederete dobbiamo
diventare tutti vegetariani o vegani in
realtà questo non è pratico per una
serie di ragioni che ora non non elenco
invece le diete flexitarian potrebbero
sfamare la crescente popolazione
mondiale con senza incrementare
l'impatto ambientale dell'Agricoltura
Cosa sono queste diete
flexitarian sono diete basate sulle
evidenze scientifiche che Sono
caratterizzate da grandi quantità di
frutta verdura proteine di origine
vegetale come soia legumi frutta secca e
semi modeste quantità di pollame
latticini
latticini pesce e uova e quantità minime
di carni rosse e carni trasformate come
gli
insaccati degli Studi dimostrano che una
transizione globale verso questo tipo di
tipo di diete apporterebbe tutta una
serie di benefici ambientali ridurrebbe
l'emissione di gass Serra e ridurrebbe
la perdita di biodiversità ma porterebbe
dei benefici importanti anche per la
nostra salute poiché ridurrebbe il
rischio di malattie croniche che sono
legate a Un'alimentazione troppo ricca
di cibi di origine animale come come Us
il diabete alcuni tipi di tumore
disturbi cardiaci sovrappeso e obesità
Inoltre come abbiamo detto si è
ipotizzato che una transizione globale a
diete flexitarian potrebbe ridurre il
rischio dell'emergere di nuove epidemie
di malattie
infettive Tuttavia oltre a pensare a
cosa mangiamo Cioè a quali tipi di cibo
se di origine vegetale o animale è
importante anche considerare come questi
cibi Vengono prodotti poiché sappiamo
che l'agricoltura è una fonte è una
delle fonti principali di degrado
ambientale tramite l'erosione del suolo
tramite l'inquinamento dei sistemi
terrestri ed acquatici attraverso la
lisciva di concimi e
pesticidi è dunque utile chiedersi se ci
possono essere delle Sinergie tra
politiche che promuovono una transizione
verso forme di agricolture più
sostenibile e politiche che promuovono
una transizione verso diete Flex
italiane prendiamo in considerazione per
esempio l'agricoltura biologica dato che
è un approccio riconosciuto e
regolamentato a livello internazionale
l'agricoltura biologica presenta una
serie Dim miglioramenti rispetto
all'agricoltura convenzionale in termini
di conservazione del suolo in termini di
riduzione dell'emissione di gas serra
per unità di superficie in termini di
inquinamento dei dei sistemi acquatici
per unità di superficie Tuttavia
purtroppo allo stesso tempo
l'agricoltura biologica al momento ha
una produttività che è del circa dell'
82% minore rispetto all'agricoltura
convenzionale a seconda dei prodotti
Questo vuol dire che per produrre la
stessa quantità di cibo dobbiamo usare
più terra e abbiamo appena detto che
l'espansione dei terreni agricoli è una
delle fonti principali di conversione
degli Habitat naturali che porta a
rischi ambientali a rischi epidemici e
allora cosa facciamo Beh io credo che
questo mette in evidenza il fatto che se
vogliamo affrontare la sostenibilità
ambientali tramite la nostra
alimentazione dobbiamo prendere in
considerazione necessariamente sia la
produzione che il consumo dei cibi
Infatti è stato fatto uno studio una
simulazione proiettata all'anno 2050 che
indica che se l'agricoltura una
conversione all'agricoltura biologica
viene integrata con altre strategie
allora sarà possibile sfamare più di 9
miliardi di persone con una riduzione
dell'impatto
complessivo ambientale quali sono queste
altre strategie una è il cambiamento dei
mangimi da soia cereali a Foraggio
grezzo l'altro come abbiamo detto una
riduzione nei nostri consumi dei cibi di
origine animale Ma poi bisogna anche
tagliare gli sprechi lungo la filiera
alimentare perché questo è importante
perché gli sprechi contribuiscono a
un'ulteriore espansione dei terini
agricoli infatti Al momento più di un
terzo di tutto il cibo prodotto viene o
perso prima che raggiunga i mercati o
sprecato dai rivenditori E dai noi
consumatori ora per attuare una
transizione alimentare globale una
ricetta uguale per tutti non sarebbe
efficace in realtà questa transizione va
adattata alle peculiarità ecologiche di
ogni regione del
paese nell'economia avanzate e nelle
Metropoli delle dei paesi in via di
sviluppo sarà necessario ridurre il
consumo eccessivo di cibi di origine
animale nelle aree rurali il problema
della malnutrizione delle famiglie più
povere andrà affrontato sia attraverso
lo sviluppo dei piccoli allevamenti ma
anche attraverso lo sviluppo Dell'Orto
cultura domestica al contrario invece ci
sono territori dove la coltivazione
agricola non è possibile e lì le
popolazioni necessariamente dovranno
continuare a dipendere dal consumo di
animali selvatici e domestici per il
loro sostentamento come per esempio
le comunità pastorali delle grandi
praterie aride le comunità di cacciatori
e raccoglitori delle foreste priali dei
Tropici e le comunità di cacciatori
dell'artico promuovere una transizione
globale verso diete Flex italiane è una
sfida enorme poiché le nostre abitudini
alimentari tendono a essere eradicate ma
non è una sfida Impossibile come
dimostrato dall'aumento di persone che
scelgono diete vegetariane o di comprare
i cibi biologici ne nei paesi paesi
occidentali infatti in alcuni paesi
purtroppo non così tanto l'Italia ancora
hanno cominciato a introdurre alcune
politiche di informazione e
incoraggiamento del consumatore verso
delle diete flexitarian andiamo ad
esplorare qualcuna di queste
politiche un primo passo sarebbe
introdurre Nella formazione di pediatri
e medici una formazione più aggiornata
sull'importanza sull'importanza della
Salute Non solo per la nostra salute
umana Ma anche per gli ecosistemi e
viceversa per la nostra salute umana
visto che noi dipendiamo Da quegli
ecosistemi focalizzarsi sui giovani è
importante poiché le nostre abitudini
alimentari tendono a formarsi nei primi
anni di vita e a rimanere persistenti
sarà quindi necessario introdurre
l'educazione a diete sane
e ecologicamente sostenibili nei
curricula
scolastici si è poi visto che applicando
delle etichette sulle confezioni
alimentari che indicano l'impatto
ambientale di queste di questi prodotti
su una scala che va dal verde al Rosso
spinge alcuni consumatori a fare scelte
di acquisti più
sostenibili ci sono poi iniziative come
i lunedì senza carne I meet free
Monday che in alcuni paesi hanno avuto
un certo
successo praticamente queste iniziative
utilizzano la tecnica del piede nella
porta per incoraggiare il consumatore a
fare dei piccoli cambiamenti come per
esempio rinunciare ogni lunedì alla
carne con l'aspettativa Che
successivamente questo consumatore possa
sviluppare un desiderio di fare anche
dei cambiamenti più importanti nella
propria dieta i ristoranti e le mense
potrebbero poi cambiare la maniera in
cui presentano i cibi nei menù e sui
banconi mettendo in evidenza i cibi di
origine vegetale e offrendone una
quantità Maggiore anche le politiche di
di approvvigionamento dei grandi luoghi
di aggregazione come scuole uffici
ospedali potrebbero incrementare la
percentuale di cibi di origine
vegetale e di e che provengono da
agricoltura
sostenibile nell'ultimo decennio si è
poi investito molto nel cercare di
creare dei sostituti della carne e dei
latticini Tra questi ci sono i prodotti
più tradizionali che sono minimamente
trasformati come il latte di soia il
tofu il seitan gli hamburger di fagioli
consumare questi prodotti
può inserire questi prodotti nella
nostra dieta ci può aiutare a limitare
il nostro impatto su ambiente e le
conseguenze negative della nostra dieta
sulla nostra salute Poi ci sonoo dei
prodotti più nuovi che cercano che sono
più trasformati poi che hanno
l'obiettivo di imitare le proprietà
organolettiche di latticini e carne per
esempio ci sono degli hamburger in cu
viene in cui viene aggiunta la lego
emoglobina di soia per imitare il sapore
del
sangue Tuttavia Tuttavia questi prodotti
altramente trasformati tendono a avere
degli impatti ambientali ancora alquanto
alti in termini di consumo di energia ed
emissioni di gas serra hanno anche dei
benefici minori A livello di salute
poiché spesso sono ricchi di sale e di
grassi saturi proprio come quei prodotti
di carne e di latticini che cercano di
imitare bene tutte queste politiche di
incoraggiamento e informazione
dovrebbero aumentare la consapevolezza
del consumatore però si è osservato che
da sole queste politiche hanno una
efficacia un po' limitata a meno che non
vengano
Eh diciamo coordinate insieme a delle
politiche fiscali che vanno a tassare il
consumo di cibi di origine animale
Diciamo che la strategia migliore è
utilizzare queste due tipi di politiche
insieme andiamo quindi adesso un pochino
a parlare delle politiche fiscali la
tassazione della
carne queste tasse sono state proposte
non solo per limitare gli impatti
ambientali del nostro consumo di animali
di animali d'allevamento ma anche per
tener conto dell'onere che la sanità
pubblica sostiene per far fronte a
malattie croniche che hanno origine in
una dieta
malsana ci sono degli esempi
dell'efficacia di queste tasse in altri
paesi per esempio ci sono delle tasse
che sono state introdotte sulle bibite
zuccherate e Sui cibi con con alto
contenuto di grassi aturi e ed è stato
osservato che queste tasse hanno
contribuito a far ridurre il consumo di
questi cibi E quindi allo stesso tempo
anche a far ridurre i casi di denti
Cariati o mancanti o i casi di
obesità ora ci potrebbe essere un
problema perché le famiglie meno
abbienti
potrebbero reagire all'aumento del
prezzo di cibi meno Sani come abbiamo
detto come bibite zuccherate o
carne diminuendo ancora di più il loro
consumo di cibi sani come frutta verdura
proteine vegetali per compensare a
questo aumento dei prezzi Allora sarà
importante che le entrate fiscali delle
tasse
eh messe sul sui prodotti di origini
animali vengano usate per sovvenzionare
il consumo di frutta di frutta verdura e
proteine vegetali queste Entrate fiscali
possono anche essere usate in altre
maniere per migliorare l'alimentazione
delle popolazioni più svantaggiate per
esempio garantendo la presenza dei
mercati rionali in tutti i quartieri e
garantendo la mensa scolastica gratuita
per le famiglie meno abbienti
ora in una società moderna come la
nostra dove siamo così abituati a non
fare caso a quello che mangiare Mangiamo
e a mangiare quantità piuttosto elevate
di carne l'introduzione di una tassa
sulla carne potrebbe farci arricciare il
naso e in realtà ci sono stati dei
sondaggi in Inghilterra che è un paese
con una forte trad izioni di consumo di
carne e latticini in cui il 62% dei
partecipanti in realtà era a favore o
non contrario all'introduzione di questa
tassa bene quindi se noi andiamo a
pensare al nostro
piatto Spero che con questo intervento
in cui vi ho parlato di tante cose
veramente di tante cose abbiamo un
pochino cominciato a riflettere insieme
sul fatto che dietro al piatto da cui
mangiamo c'è un mondo c'è un mondo vero
E allora mi piacerebbe che domani
dopodomani quando andiamo a fare la
nostra spesa settimanale cominciamo un
pochino a decidere cosa possiamo fare
noi per cambiare la nostra alimentazione
vogliamo non so vogliamo eliminare la
carne tutte led oppure semplicemente
guardiamo la nostra spesa settimanale
come se fosse contenuta in un
piatto Dovremmo cercare di comporre
quella spesa settimanale per la maggior
parte con frutta e verdura e con cibi di
origine di di proteine di origine
vegetale questo non vuol dire che
dobbiamo eliminare la carne eliminare
formaggi Ma dobbiamo decisamente ridurne
le quantità cioè per esempio in questo
grafico dietro a me la quantità relativa
proporzionale di carne e latticini che
dovremmo mangiare è rappresentata da
triangolini Turchese e
rosso nel libro dei mutamenti che nella
tradizione cinese è
usato
per tradurre per capire i grandi
cambiamenti della vita e del cosmo c'è
un simbolo che si chiama il cambiamento
del piccolo questo simbolo Sta a
indicare che quando ci troviamo di
fronte a un problema gigante come un
monolita basta una singola persona che
comincia a scalfire via dei pezzi di
quel monolita perché altre persone si
uniscano a lei nello
scalfire qualunque cambiamento
alimentare nella dieta di ciascuno di
noi può contribuire a scalfire quel
monolita che sono le crisi ambientali
della nostra epoca basta iniziare e pian
piano altri si uniranno a noi nel
cambiamento
[Applauso]
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie